Cette vidéo est destinée aux étudiants
de Prépa ECG (anciennement Prépa HEC). En
effet, les épreuves de dissertation de culture
générale des concours des grandes écoles
de commerce qui auront lieu l’année prochaine,
en 2024 — ces épreuves de dissertation
porteront sur le thème de la violence.
Deux petites précisions avant de commencer
à vous faire découvrir ce thème.
Tout d’abord, vous n’avez pas besoin de
prendre de notes en regardant cette vidéo,
car vous pouvez télécharger mon kit de survie
sur le thème de la violence.
C’est un fichier Google Docs d’une vingtaine
de pages qui contient l’essentiel à connaître
sur le thème de la violence pour réussir
vos dissertations. Non seulement il est organisé
efficacement, mais en plus vous pouvez accéder
directement à la partie qui vous intéresse
grâce au sommaire dynamique sur la gauche
(personnellement, je suis fan de Google Docs
depuis que cette fonctionnalité existe).
D’ailleurs, vous pouvez faire la même chose
avec cette vidéo grâce aux chapitres qui
apparaissent dans la barre de lecture (je
les ai également listés dans la description).
Enfin, vous pouvez même customizer ce document
Google Docs en créant une copie personnelle.
Mais bon, méfiance tout de même, parce qu’il
y a déjà beaucoup de choses, et plus vous
aurez de connaissances à gérer, moins vous
les maîtriserez, et donc moins vous serez
en mesure de réussir vos dissertations.
Pour accéder à ce kit de survie, cliquez
sur le lien qui apparaît en haut à droite
de la vidéo ; ou bien cliquez sur celui qui
est dans la description ; ou bien encore tapez
directement 1000idcg.com/violence dans la
barre de recherche.
Ensuite, il vous suffira de vous inscrire
avec votre adresse e-mail ; de confirmer votre
inscription en ouvrant le premier e-mail que
vous recevrez ; et vous recevrez alors ce
kit de survie dans l’e-mail suivant.
S’il y a un souci, vous pouvez m’écrire
à romain@1000idcg.com.
Seconde précision préliminaire, inspirée
par le fait que pas mal d’élèves m’ont
déjà posé la même question : oui, je vais
bien proposer mes 50 paragraphes « tout cuits
» sur le thème de la violence. Comme chaque
année, il n’y a que 100 places, c’est
pourquoi certains élèves ont déjà réservé
la leur.
Si ça vous intéresse, cliquez sur le lien
qui apparaît en haut à droite de la vidéo
; ou bien cliquez sur celui qui est dans la
description ; ou bien encore tapez directement
1000idcg.com/50ptc dans la barre de recherche.
Bien sûr, vous pouvez me poser vos questions
par e-mail, en écrivant à romain@1000idcg.com.
Voilà voilà, c’est bon pour les précisions
préliminaires. Je vais maintenant vous présenter
l’essentiel à connaître sur le thème
de la violence pour réussir vos dissertations
de culture générale.
Caractéristiques du thème
Je vais répondre à deux questions pour mettre
en évidence les principales caractéristiques
du thème de la violence :
1. Est-ce un thème original ?
2. Est-ce un thème précis ou large ?
Est-ce un thème original ?
En Prépa ECG/HEC, le thème « la violence
» n’est jamais tombé depuis les années
1990. Le seul thème passé qui s’en rapproche
est « le mal » (2001).
Alors que la violence est une obsession de
l’être humain — elle est avec la sexualité,
un des deux stimuli les plus puissants pour
capter son attention — on ne peut cependant
pas dire qu’elle soit un thème classique
en culture générale :
* les grandes œuvres de la littérature et
de la philosophie occidentales ne traitent
pas spécifiquement de la violence (si ce
n’est de manière adjacente, lorsqu’elles
traitent de la guerre notamment) ;
* ce n’est pas une notion du programme de
philosophie de terminale ;
* ce n’est pas un axe du programme de culture
générale de 1ère année.
En conclusion, le thème de la violence est
plutôt original.
Est-ce un thème précis ou large ?
D’un côté, le thème de la violence semble
précis parce que la polysémie du mot est
limitée (la définition du dictionnaire de
l’Académie française est relativement
courte) ; parce que ce thème est moins général
que d’autres (comme le monde — le thème
de l’année dernière —, par exemple,
ou le mal) ; parce que le nombre de sous-thèmes
paraît limité.
D’un autre côté, le thème de la violence
semble large dans la mesure où c’est une
obsession de l’être humain ; dans la mesure
où on distingue de nombreuses formes de violence
(physique, psychologique, verbale, sexuelle,
domestique, économique, politique, symbolique,
structurelle, individuelle, collective, etc.)
; et encore dans la mesure où elle est une
dimension majeure de l’histoire récente
(disons depuis la Révolution française,
et tout particulièrement le XXe siècle).
En définitive, comparé à tous les thèmes
qui sont tombés aux concours des grandes
écoles de commerce, le thème de la violence
est plutôt précis.
Définitions essentielles
Je vais tout d’abord définir la notion
de violence elle-même en partant de son étymologie.
Je vais ensuite vous donner les définitions
simples d’une dizaine de concepts-clés
qui sont liés à la notion de violence.
Comment définir la violence ?
Sur le plan de l’étymologie, le nom commun
« violence » vient du latin violentia, qui
signifie essentiellement « force », et qui
sert notamment à qualifier la capacité de
certains phénomènes naturels à faire subir
une contrainte physique à l’homme (la force
du vent, par exemple). Le mot latin violentia
vient lui-même du latin vis, qui signifie
également « force », mais au sens de « force
vitale », d’« énergie en action », c’est-à-dire
ce qui fait mouvoir les êtres vivants. Dans
cette perspective, la violence est liée à
la vie elle-même.
L’idée que suggère l’étymologie latine
est donc qu’il y a violence lorsque l’énergie
qui anime la vie se fait sentir physiquement
(au point d’engendrer un dommage).
En français, le sens le plus courant du nom
commun « violence » concerne en effet les
actions physiques et les comportements.
Pour faire simple, il faut distinguer deux
usages du mot « violence » :
1. La force elle-même — C’est le fait
d'agir sur quelqu'un ou de le faire agir contre
sa volonté en employant la force ou l'intimidation.
Les dommages sont en général physiques,
mais ils peuvent être, et ils sont de plus
en plus psychologiques (comme dans le harcèlement).
On parle par exemple de la violence révolutionnaire,
des violences policières, ou de la violence
conjugale. Dans cet usage, la violence s’oppose
à la paix et à l’ordre.
2. La manière d’être de la force — C’est
essentiellement le fait que la force n’est
pas contenue (et l’homme estime qu’elle
devrait l’être parce qu’elle risque d’engendrer
un dommage). On parle par exemple de la violence
du vent, de la violence d’un coup (le coup
constituant en lui-même une violence), ou
de la violence d’une accusation. Dans cet
usage, la violence s’oppose à la mesure.
La langue ordinaire distingue certaines formes
de violence, dont notamment la violence physique,
la violence verbale, la violence psychologique,
la violence sexuelle, ou encore la violence
structurelle (lorsque l’organisation de
la société, la configuration hiérarchique
de ses éléments est source de violence)
et la violence symbolique (idée issue de
la sociologie de Bourdieu).
Quelles sont les idées les plus importantes
?
Voici les principales idées liées à la
notion de violence :
* Agression : Atteinte à l’intégrité
physique ou psychologique d’un organisme.
Ressentir le bruit comme une agression.
* Barbarie : Caractère d’une violence dont
l’excès est rapporté à la prétendue
sauvagerie de la vie humaine dans l’état
précédant la civilisation. Pousser la répression
jusqu’à la barbarie.
* Brutalité : Caractère d’une chose dont
l’intensité frappe l’esprit humain de
la même manière que l’intensité du comportement
d’une brute (un animal dépourvu de raison)
frappe l’esprit. La brutalité d’une offensive
militaire.
* Coopération : Entente entre les membres
d'un groupe en vue d'un but commun. Travailler
en étroite coopération.
* Cruauté : Caractère d’une violence qui
laisse penser que son auteur est insensible
à la souffrance de la victime. Traiter ses
ennemis avec cruauté.
* Domination : Action ou capacité d’un
individu ou d’une entité à imposer sa
volonté à quelqu’un ou quelque chose.
L’Empire romain étend sa domination.
* Dommage : Préjudice physique ou psychologique
causé par un tiers. Les dommages incalculables
de la guerre.
* Force : Capacité d’un être vivant ou
d’une chose à exercer une action. Ne plus
avoir la force d’avancer.
* Guerre : Conflit armé entre des groupes
humains organisés. L’art de la guerre.
* Intégrité : État d’un ensemble (une
chose ou un être) complet, dont il ne manque
aucune des parties. Une atteinte à l’intégrité
physique.
* Intimidation : Action de susciter la crainte
chez un être vivant. Ne pas céder à des
manœuvres d’intimidation.
* Paix : Absence de trouble dans les relations
entre individus ou entre groupes d’individus.
Faire la paix.
* Peur : Émotion pénible liée à la conscience
d’un danger. La peur de la mort.
* Souffrance : Douleur physique ou morale.
La souffrance animale.
* Torture : Souffrance physique intense infligée
à quelqu'un (souvent pour obtenir des aveux).
Un instrument de torture.
* Tyrannie : Domination qui, parce qu’elle
n’est pas encadrée par des limites, recourt
à la violence et commet l’injustice. La
tyrannie d’un dirigeant qui réprime les
oppositions à sa politique.
* Vengeance : Acte d’infliger un dommage
en réponse à un dommage subi. Goûter le
plaisir de la vengeance.
Vue d'ensemble sur la violence humaine
Dans cette partie, mon objectif est de vous
brosser les grandes lignes de l’histoire
de la violence humaine et des interprétations
que la pensée occidentale en a données.
Ma perspective est donc principalement historique
et philosophique. Toutefois, je mobiliserai
aussi d’autres champs du savoir qui permettent
de mieux comprendre la violence (notamment
l’anthropologie et la psychologie).
Voici les limites de ma synthèse :
* Comme la violence est un phénomène et
un enjeu majeur de la vie humaine, la quantité
de faits, d’idées et d’œuvres qu’on
peut mentionner est infinie. Je me contenterai
donc de mentionner des repères essentiels.
* Comme une vue d’ensemble est une synthèse,
je vais sacrifier les détails et simplifier
(parfois dans une proportion qui peut paraître
excessive). Libre à vous de compléter, mais
rappelez-vous que votre objectif n’est pas
d’accumuler les connaissances (il est de
réussir une épreuve de dissertation).
* Ma synthèse embrasse l’histoire de l’ensemble
de l’humanité, mais comme la plupart des
travaux sur le même sujet, elle donne une
place plus importante à l’Occident. Elle
privilégie également les violences physiques,
qui sont celles auxquelles renvoie en priorité
le mot dans la langue courante.
Gardez donc bien à l’esprit, lorsque vous
lisez ou écoutez ma synthèse, que l’intérêt
est d’avoir une bonne perspective d’ensemble
du thème. Ainsi, vous vous repérerez mieux
dans le champ intellectuel sur lequel vous
devrez disserter cette année.
Quelle différence entre les violences humaine
et animale ?
Voici les principales conclusions de l’éthologie
(la science du comportement des espèces animales
dans leur milieu naturel) :
* les animaux d'espèces différentes ou bien
s'évitent, ou bien s'affrontent dans une
relation de prédation ;
* l'agression fonctionne comme un instinct
(c’est-à-dire de manière programmée et
automatique) surtout à l'intérieur de l'espèce
;
* l’agression au sein de l’espèce intervient
dans la répartition des ressources, dans
la sexualité, et dans l’établissement
d’une hiérarchie stable ;
* elle est peu dangereuse : les armes des
animaux sont limitées (griffes, dents, cornes,
etc.), et l’agression s’assortit de comportements
de ritualisation qui épargnent le plus faible
;
* il existe quand même des comportements
pathologiques (lorsque la ritualisation est
défaillante) : animaux tueurs, autoagression,
cannibalisme à l'égard des petits, attaques
pathologiques, guerres à l'intérieur du
groupe, etc.
D’après ces conclusions, la violence animale
serait liée à un instinct qui organise les
relations des individus à travers leurs affrontements.
Cet instinct existerait chez l’homme tant
qu’il vit dans des groupes dits « naturels
» (maximum une centaine de membres) parce
que chaque membre connaît intimement les
autres membres.
Mais l’instinct déraille dans les grands
groupes (dits « artificiels »). La distance
entre les individus les empêche de se connaître
intimement et de communiquer efficacement,
d’où l’échec de la ritualisation. De
surcroît, les armes et l’inventivité technique
humaines démultiplient les ravages.
Le zoologiste autrichien du XXe siècle Konrad
Lorenz met par exemple en évidence le fait
que les armes modernes engendrent un aléa
moral : l’homme qui appuie sur un bouton
n’a pas à en subir les conséquences.
« L'invention d'armes artificielles troubla
l'équilibre entre les possibilités de tuer
et les inhibitions sociales. »
Konrad Lorenz, L’agression : une histoire
naturelle du mal
L’homme serait donc un animal agressif qui
pratique à vaste échelle ce qui passe chez
les autres animaux pour une défaillance de
l’instinct.
Que sait-on de la violence chez les premiers
hommes ?
Les corps d’hommes préhistoriques qu’on
retrouve révèlent souvent, à l’analyse,
des traces de violence. C’est par exemple
le cas d’Ötzi, l’homme des glaces découvert
en 1991 au nord-est de l’Italie. Alors que
les scientifiques pensaient d’abord qu’il
était mort de froid dans une crevasse où
il était tombé, des radiologues découvrent
une pointe de flèche fichée dans son épaule
; puis on trouve des entailles non cicatrisées
au niveau de ses mains, ainsi que des blessures
à la tête et au torse ; enfin, les analyses
ADN identifient des traces de sang d’autres
individus. La conclusion s’impose : Ötzi
était un homme dangereux. Il faisait probablement
partie d’un groupe qui se livrait à de
violents pillages et se serait heurté à
une tribu voisine.
Cet exemple laisse donc penser que l’homme
préhistorique n’était pas pacifique, et
qu’il avait de fortes chances de voir son
corps meurtri.
On peut mettre cette hypothèse à l’épreuve
en s’intéressant au comportement des primates
proches des ancêtres de l’homme préhistorique.
Les chimpanzés (les animaux les plus proches
des êtres humains) passaient pour une espèce
essentiellement pacifique. Les anthropologues
pensaient que les conflits entre les groupes
de chimpanzés ne dépassaient jamais le stade
de l’intimidation. Concrètement, lorsqu’un
sous-groupe en quête de nourriture dans la
forêt rencontre un sous-groupe d’une autre
communauté, ils se livrent simplement à
des démonstrations de force jusqu’à ce
que l’un des deux groupes cède.
La primatologue britannique Jane Goodall rétablit
la vérité dans les années 1960. Observant
des chimpanzés dans leur milieu naturel sur
de longues périodes (ce qu’elle est la
première à faire), elle montre que l’agression
mortelle fait partie du répertoire normal
du comportement des chimpanzés. En particulier,
un groupe de chimpanzés mâles peuvent faire
preuve d’une sauvagerie meurtrière lorsqu’ils
rencontrent un plus petit groupe d’une autre
communauté ou un individu isolé (si c’est
une femelle, ils peuvent la violer, voire
tuer et même manger son petit).
« Les attaques par d'autres chimpanzés sont
la deuxième cause de mortalité à Gombe
(Tanzanie), après les maladies. »
Jane Goodall, Through a Window
Comment expliquer la violence des chimpanzés
? Dans la perspective évolutionniste, l’agression
est un moyen efficace, pour les mâles, d’accaparer
des ressources (du territoire, donc de la
nourriture, et aussi les femelles du groupe
vaincu). Mais ils ne s’adonnent pas à n’importe
quel type d’agression : ils privilégient
les combats inégaux — le groupe des agresseurs
essaie en général d’être trois fois plus
nombreux que le groupe des agressés — afin
de réduire les risques. Cette situation se
produit notamment lorsque des chimpanzés
affamés se mettent en quête de nourriture
seuls, car les arbres à fruit sont distribués
de manière irrégulière sur le territoire.
Les bonobos sont d’autres primates (dont
les hommes sont proches) apparemment peu portés
à la violence. Ils ont même été surnommés
les « chimpanzés hippies » (le bonobo est
un chimpanzé nain) parce que cette espèce
serait à la fois pacifique, matriarcale,
voluptueuse (ils dissocient la sexualité
de la reproduction) et herbivore (ils ont
donné leur nom à un restaurant végétarien
de New York). Cette vision est cependant à
nuancer, car les groupes de bonobos qui l’ont
inspirée sont privilégiés. On a constaté
que les groupes moins privilégiés sont plus
agressifs (quoique plus pacifiques que les
chimpanzés communs).
On peut également éclairer la propension
à la violence des ancêtres de l’homme
en s’intéressant aux tribus de chasseurs-cueilleurs.
On a cru jusqu’à la fin du XXe siècle
que leur violence était très limitée (notamment
en comparaison des carnages dont sont capables
les sociétés plus avancées). On pensait
que les affrontements tribaux étaient essentiellement
rituels et symboliques. À quoi ressemblaient-ils
? Concrètement, deux camps se menacent et
s’insultent à distance ; ils se visent
avec des flèches et des lances ; puis ils
arrêtent les frais dès les premiers blessés
ou tués. L’historien américain William
Eckhardt, qui a écrit une histoire quantitative
de la guerre en 1992, estime que les tribus
étaient trop petites et qu’elles avaient
trop peu d’armes pour mener une guerre d’envergure.
Des anthropologues réfutent cette conclusion
au tournant du XXIe siècle. L’idée essentielle
qui ressort de leurs travaux, c’est que
ce ne sont pas les affrontements bruyants
des tribus qui font beaucoup de victimes,
mais les raids, c’est-à-dire les attaques
sournoises (la source de la violence des chasseurs-cueilleurs
serait donc le même type de comportements
que chez les chimpanzés).
Concrètement, un petit groupe d’hommes
se glissent furtivement dans un village ennemi
avant le lever du jour, puis décochent des
flèches contre les habitants qui sortent
de leur hutte. Ils peuvent ainsi tuer un grand
nombre de personnes mal réveillées. Le temps
que les villageois organisent la riposte,
les assaillants auront déjà décampé. S’ils
sont suffisamment nombreux, ils peuvent tuer
tous les hommes et enlever les femmes. D’autres
types d’attaques sont possibles, comme l’embuscade
ou certaines ruses. Ces attaques susceptibles
de décimer une tribu ne sont pas forcément
des événements rares.
« En général, les guerres dans les sociétés
préétatiques étaient à la fois fréquentes
et importantes. »
Lawrence Keeley, Les guerres préhistoriques
Cet anthropologue américain estime même
que la guerre préhistorique était plus meurtrière
(en proportion de la population) que la guerre
moderne, et que ce que nous appelons des « génocides
» étaient monnaie courante.
Voici quelques autres faits révélateurs
:
* selon les enquêtes ethnographiques, environ
les deux tiers des groupes de chasseurs-cueilleurs
sont en guerre au moins une fois tous les
deux ans ;
* ces groupes se battent souvent pour se venger,
et c’est ce motif qui les incite à massacrer
leurs ennemis jusqu’au dernier, afin d’éviter
un match retour ;
* les guerriers sont capables d’atrocités
(par exemple, ils imbibent les pointes des
flèches de poison, ils les conçoivent de
manière à ce qu’elles se brisent au moment
de l’impact, ou encore ils torturent leurs
prisonniers) ;
* le cannibalisme est largement répandu dans
la préhistoire humaine, au point que nous
posséderions des gènes qui protègent des
maladies transmises par les pratiques cannibales.
L’homme est-il violent par nature ?
Les penseurs de référence de la culture
occidentale ont répondu à cette question
sans disposer de connaissances fiables sur
la vie humaine avant la civilisation.
Pour faire simple, les deux positions clés
sont, d’une part, la vision pessimiste développée
par Thomas Hobbes, un philosophe anglais du
XVIIe siècle, dans le Léviathan ; et d’autre
part la vision optimiste développée par
Jean-Jacques Rousseau, un philosophe genevois
du XVIIIe siècle, dans son Discours sur l’origine
de l’inégalité. Leur désaccord fondamental
découle de leurs conceptions différentes
de l’état de nature, c’est-à-dire la
condition (hypothétique) des êtres humains
avant l'établissement de la société et
des lois.
En quoi Hobbes est-il pessimiste ?
À ses yeux, les premiers hommes vivaient
dans un état d’anarchie violente, ce qu’il
a fameusement décrit comme « une guerre
de tous contre tous ».
« La vie de l’homme est solitaire, besogneuse,
pénible, quasi animale et brève. »
Thomas Hobbes, Léviathan
Pourquoi l’état de nature serait-il fondamentalement
hostile ? Selon Hobbes, c’est tout d’abord
un problème de défiance. Comme l’homme
originel craint d’être attaqué à tout
moment, il a intérêt à prendre lui-même
l’initiative d’attaquer, c’est-à-dire
qu’il attaque par anticipation (« la meilleure
défense, c’est l’attaque », dit un adage
souvent attribué à Napoléon). Mais la source
primordiale de la violence de l’homme de
l’état de nature est psychologique : il
a besoin de se sentir reconnu par ses semblables.
Il tend donc à interpréter le moindre signe
de mésestime comme une agression insupportable,
suffisante à déclencher les hostilités.
Cette sensibilité le met dans une disposition
permanente au combat. C’est le sens de la
célèbre formule du dramaturge latin Plaute
« l’homme est un loup pour l’homme » (qui
sera popularisée à partir de la Renaissance,
et reprise par Hobbes dans Du citoyen).
Les premiers hommes vivent donc dans un état
d’expectative qui empêche toute activité
sociale productive, puisque la violence risque
de réduire à néant les fruits de l’effort.
C’est pour cette raison que Hobbes justifie
l’instauration d’un État assez fort pour
interdire les violences privées. Il compare
la puissance de cet État à celle du Léviathan
de La Bible, un monstre marin colossal capable
d’anéantir le monde.
Cette solution repose sur une conception de
l’acte de violence qui met en présence
3 parties qui ont chacune un motif de recourir
à la violence :
1. l’agresseur qui veut imposer sa volonté
à une victime ;
2. la victime, qui riposte pour se défendre
;
3. le témoin, qui intervient pour minimiser
les dégâts collatéraux.
La violence entre les combattants peut être
qualifiée de guerre ; la violence exercée
par le témoin contre les combattants peut
être qualifiée de loi. Pour résumer d’un
mot la théorie du Léviathan, la loi vaut
mieux que la guerre.
En quoi Rousseau est-il optimiste ?
À ses yeux, la violence est quasiment absente
de l’état de nature. Hobbes se trompe parce
qu’il projette les passions propres à la
société.
« Le calme des passions et l’ignorance
du vice les empêchent de mal faire. »
Jean-Jacques Rousseau, Discours sur l’origine
de l’inégalité
Pourquoi l’état de nature serait-il fondamentalement
pacifique ? En premier lieu, c’est une question
de densité de population. Rousseau postule
que l’homme préhistorique menait une vie
isolée, car les individus étaient dispersés
sur la Terre (contrairement à la promiscuité
dans laquelle vivent les hommes civilisés).
Du coup, les rencontres, et donc les risques
de conflit sont rares. En deuxième lieu,
l’environnement naturel satisfait les besoins
de l’homme, ce qui rend la prédation inutile.
En troisième lieu, les passions sociales
— la jalousie, pour faire simple — sont
absentes à l’état de nature, de telle
sorte que la violence liée à l’honneur
n’existe pas. Enfin, même si l’homme
naturel n’est ni bon ni mauvais — ses
actes lui sont dictés par la survie — il
n’aime pas la violence parce qu’il éprouve
de la pitié, la répugnance innée à voir
souffrir son semblable, qu’on décèle déjà
chez les animaux.
La vision de Rousseau a des implications importantes,
dont notamment :
* l’idée que c’est la civilisation, au
sens de l’organisation de la vie collective
en de grands groupes artificiels, qui est
responsable de la violence humaine ;
* la substitution de l’idée d’innocence
originelle à celle de péché originel (selon
saint Augustin, la désobéissance d’Adam
et Ève, les premiers humains créés par
Dieu, prédispose ensuite les hommes à faire
le mal) ;
* la révolution de l’éducation occidentale
à partir de l’idée que l’enfant est
un être innocent et pur auquel il faut laisser
la liberté de se développer naturellement
plutôt que de lui imposer une discipline
précoce.
Qui, de Hobbes ou de Rousseau, a raison ?
Le progrès du savoir accompli ces derniers
siècles nous permet de conclure que les deux
positions déforment très probablement la
réalité de la violence humaine. Celle de
Hobbes exagère la propension de l’homme
préhistorique à la violence comme celle
de Rousseau exagère l’innocence de cet
homme.
Les champs modernes du savoir apportent de
nouveaux éclairages :
* L’anthropologie met en lumière l’importance
de la chasse. Cette activité aurait développé
chez les hommes l’agressivité propre aux
carnivores. Elle aurait en même temps entraîné
la sophistication de la coopération — une
équipe de chasseurs peut s’attaquer à
du gros gibier — et le perfectionnement
des outils (notamment des armes). Enfin, comme
la chasse est une source importante d’acquisition
de nourriture, les chasseurs (dont la compétence
est relative à la prise de risque et à la
violence) dominent dans la tribu.
* La psychologie met en lumière la coexistence
de motivations qui favorisent la violence
et d’autres motivations qui en détournent.
D’un côté, la satisfaction des besoins,
l’ambition, la rivalité, la vengeance,
et le sadisme peuvent rendre l’homme violent
; mais de l’autre côté, l’empathie,
la maîtrise de soi, le sens moral, et la
raison l’aiguillent vers la coopération
et l’altruisme. La psychologie évolutionniste,
l’école dominante dans la psychologie contemporaine,
pose que la tendance à la violence est stratégique,
c’est-à-dire qu’en règle générale,
l’homme ne recourt à la violence que lorsqu’il
estime que les gains potentiels sont élevés
et les risques faibles (les hommes [et les
chimpanzés, comme on l’a vu] ont une âme
de guerrier quand ils sont à dix contre un).
* La neurophysiologie, qui étudie le fonctionnement
et l'organisation du système nerveux, met
en lumière divers types d’agressivités.
Il y en a une propre au cerveau reptilien,
qui est le siège des comportements de survie
de l’individu et de l’espèce, des peurs
ancestrales et des mécanismes de reconnaissance
de base ; il y en a une propre au système
limbique, qui est le siège des motivations
et des émotions ; enfin, il y en a une propre
au néocortex, qui permet les anticipations,
les choix et le contrôle de l’action volontaire.
* La sociologie, qui étudie la société
comme un tout qui a ses propriétés propres,
met en évidence divers rôles de la violence
humaine dans une communauté : par exemple,
la violence initiatique (le bizutage) qui
intègre un nouveau membre dans un groupe
; la violence qui sert à contester la répartition
des ressources ; la violence « révolutionnaire
» qui sert à contester la hiérarchie. Ces
types de violence peuvent exister aussi bien
dans une tribu d’une centaine de chasseurs-cueilleurs
que dans une nation de 70 millions de citoyens.
* L’économie met en lumière la rentabilité
de la paix. Le commerce est un jeu à somme
positive, c’est-à-dire que toutes les parties
gagnent à coopérer. Or, le commerçant a
intérêt à ce que ses clients et ses partenaires
soient animés par des sentiments favorables
à son égard. C’est la fameuse idée du
« doux commerce », selon laquelle les interactions
économiques pacifient les rapports humains.
Les choses semblent toutefois plus compliquées
dans les faits.
Quid de la violence dans les anciennes civilisations
?
________________
Petite interruption parce que je me dis que
si tu m’écoutes, c’est pas pour devenir
philosophe professionnel. Non, tu m’écoutes
parce que tu veux te préparer de la manière
la plus efficace qui soit pour réussir tes
dissertations de culture générale.
Et du coup je me dis que tu as probablement
compris qu’un cours de 300 pages n’est
pas la solution. Au contraire, c’est plutôt
le problème.
Si tu as conscience de ce problème, alors
j’ai une solution pour toi.
Chaque année, je prépare 50 paragraphes
modèles sur le thème que j’ai baptisés
— avec un brin de provocation — 50 paragraphes
« tout cuits ».
L’idée est simple : tu n’as plus besoin
de rédiger toi-même le développement de
tes dissertations puisque tu connais déjà
une cinquantaine de paragraphes prérédigés
qui permettent de défendre tous les arguments
envisageables sur tous les sujets envisageables
avec les références idéales. Et si je sais
que ça marche pour tous les sujets, c’est
parce que je traite moi-même tous les sujets
possibles dans un premier temps (c’est comme
ça que je trouve les arguments des paragraphes).
D’ailleurs, depuis plusieurs années, je
fournis avec les paragraphes une cinquantaine
de plans détaillés modèles.
Les avantages de cette solution, c’est que
tu n’as plus besoin de cours, que tu n’as
plus besoin de chercher un plan ni des arguments,
et que tu seras surnoté(e) parce que les
paragraphes sont bien mieux rédigés que
si tu les rédigeais toi-même (ce qui fait
que ta copie sort du lot). Les élèves me
disent aussi qu’ils sont beaucoup moins
stressés pendant l’épreuve, qu’ils se
sentent confiants et à l’aise.
Bref, mes 50 paragraphes « tout cuits » te
feront gagner facilement et rapidement des
points... tout en gagnant beaucoup de temps.
Ce qui te permet de gagner des points dans
les autres matières, tout particulièrement
en maths.
Si tu veux en savoir plus, clique sur le lien
qui apparaît en haut à droite de la vidéo
; ou bien clique sur celui qui est dans la
description ; ou bien encore tape directement
1000idcg.com/50ptc dans la barre de recherche.
Et puis si tu as des questions, écris-moi
à romain@1000idcg.com.
________________
Les anciennes civilisations qui servent de
repères pour la culture occidentale sont
les civilisations bibliques, la Grèce antique
et la Rome antique.
L’Iliade et l’Odyssée d’Homère offrent
un aperçu de la violence de la Grèce antique.
Le récit se déroule à la période mythique
de la guerre de Troie, aux environs du XIIIe
siècle avant J.-C, mais comme il a été
rédigé bien plus tard, il reflète en réalité
la vie (et en particulier la propension à
la violence) des tribus et chefferies en Méditerranée
orientale dans la première moitié du Ier
millénaire avant J.-C.
Les hommes de cette époque voient la guerre
comme un aspect inexorable de l’existence.
Leur fatalisme se trahit par le fait qu’ils
rapportent la guerre à la colère des dieux
plutôt que de l’envisager comme un problème
humain soluble.
« Nous sommes des hommes à qui Zeus, je
le vois, inflige le destin de dévider le
fil des guerres douloureuses, de nos plus
jeunes ans jusqu’à notre vieillesse, jusqu’à
l’heure où chacun de nous doit succomber.
»
Ulysse dans l’Odyssée d’Homère
Les descriptions d’Homère sont cohérentes
avec les connaissances archéologiques, ethnographiques
et historiques dont nous disposons. Elles
montrent que les guerres de la Grèce antique
sont tout aussi totales que les guerres des
nations modernes. Voici comment se produit
une attaque : les soldats approchent du rivage
dans des embarcations rapides, ce qui leur
permet de mettre à sac les habitations côtières
avant l’intervention des voisins ; en général,
ils tuent les hommes ; ils pillent le bétail
et les autres biens meubles ; ils enlèvent
les femmes, les asservissent et les violent
(les héros de l’Iliade considèrent les
femmes comme un butin légitime). Les combats
infligent au corps humain une violence digne
de nos films d’horreur, et puis laissent
des monceaux de cadavres en délitement sur
le champ de bataille.
Ce scénario explique la psychologie des Grecs
du temps d’Homère. Les hommes vivent dans
l’hypothèse d’une mort soudaine et violente.
Leurs femmes ont peur pour leurs maris et
enfants. Elles guettent avec inquiétude des
voiles à l’horizon qui peuvent être annonciatrices
d’une nouvelle vie de viols et d’esclavage.
L’Ancien Testament (qui est la première
partie de la Bible chrétienne, composée
d'un ensemble de textes religieux et historiques
du peuple juif) offre un aperçu des vies
et des valeurs des civilisations proche-orientales
au milieu du Ier millénaire avant J.-C. Or,
la violence est un thème majeur de l’Ancien
Testament.
Parmi les épisodes de violence les plus célèbres,
on peut citer :
* le meurtre d'Abel par son frère aîné
Caïn, ce qui fait de Caïn le premier meurtrier
de l’humanité (Abel et Caïn sont les fils
d’Adam et Ève) ;
* le massacre des habitants de Sodome et Gomorrhe
(qui sont des villes voisines) : Dieu décide
de les engloutir dans un déluge de soufre
et de feu pour punir leurs péchés (que les
théologiens réduiront à la sexualité non
reproductive) ;
* le sacrifice d'Isaac : les valeurs morales
d’Abraham, le père du peuple hébreu, sont
mises à l’épreuve lorsque Dieu lui ordonne
d’emmener son fils Isaac au sommet d’une
montagne, de lui lier les mains, de l’égorger
et de brûler son corps en guise de sacrifice
— Isaac n’est épargné que parce qu’au
dernier moment, un ange vient arrêter la
main du père.
Les récits de l’Ancien Testament incluent
les violences les plus graves : l’esclavage,
le viol, la torture, la mutilation, le sacrifice,
et même le génocide de tribus voisines.
Ils banalisent la peine de mort, prescrite
pour l’adultère, l’homosexualité, le
manque de respect envers les parents, ou encore
le blasphème. Comme l’illustre l’épisode
de Sodome et Gomorrhe, la justice divine est
d’une sévérité extrême : elle autorise
le génocide de peuples entiers (Hittites,
Amorrites, Cananéens, etc.). La vengeance
humaine est légitimée par la loi du talion,
qui apparaît à plusieurs reprises avec la
même image de l’œil et de la dent. Enfin,
les pauvres animaux prennent cher. Ils sont
régulièrement sacrifiés pour honorer Dieu,
célébrer des fêtes religieuses, expier
les péchés, ou encore sceller des alliances.
« Mais si malheur arrive, tu paieras vie
pour vie, œil pour œil, dent pour dent,
main pour main, pied pour pied, brûlure pour
brûlure, blessure pour blessure, meurtrissure
pour meurtrissure. »
Ancien Testament, Exode 21,23-25
En conclusion, l’Ancien Testament dépeint
un monde d’une sauvagerie stupéfiante.
Les gens réduisent en esclavage, violent,
assassinent des membres de leur famille proche.
Les chefs de guerre massacrent des civils
de façon indiscriminée, y compris des enfants.
Les femmes sont achetées, vendues, enlevées
comme objets sexuels. Quant à Dieu, il torture
et massacre hommes et femmes par centaines
de milliers pour simple désobéissance, ou
même sans aucune raison. Les violences atroces
ne sont pas rares et elles impliquent toutes
les principales figures du récit.
Le judaïsme et le christianisme ont cependant
donné plus d’importance à des textes sacrés
bien moins violents que l’Ancien Testament,
le Talmud (qui compile le savoir religieux
des rabbins) pour le judaïsme, et le Nouveau
Testament (qui relate notamment le parcours
de Jésus-Christ) pour le christianisme.
Plus particulièrement, on oppose souvent
la conception chrétienne de l’amour à
la violence dépeinte et valorisée dans l’Ancien
Testament. L’innovation en termes de valeurs
est double : premier versant, Jésus-Christ
prescrit d’aimer son prochain comme soi-même
; et second versant, il prescrit d’aimer
tous les hommes, quels qu’ils soient, indépendamment
de leur mérite comme de leur identité (cela
inclut donc les ennemis). Le chrétien a ainsi
un devoir de bienveillance universelle et
inconditionnelle qui constitue un idéal de
non-violence. Envisagé dans une perspective
historique, le Nouveau Testament indique une
évolution des mentalités chez les peuples
des deux premiers siècles.
La Rome antique est une civilisation ambivalente
à l’égard de la violence.
D’un côté, elle est un exemple de la capacité
d’un empire, une organisation politique
autoritaire qui s’étend sur des peuples
distincts, à pacifier les rapports humains.
C’est ce qu’on appelle la Pax Romana (« Paix
Romaine »). L’empire romain a connu une
période de stabilité politique et de prospérité
qui s’étend grosso modo sur les deux premiers
siècles (qui sont également la période
de l’histoire et de l’écriture du Nouveau
Testament). La Rome de cette époque connaît
peu de conflits internes, pas de guerres majeures,
consolide le pouvoir impérial, développe
les infrastructures à travers les provinces,
et enfin promeut le commerce et la culture.
Cette paix impériale romaine illustre les
deux théories de référence concernant l’effet
de l’organisation politique sur la violence
:
1. la théorie du Léviathan de Hobbes, selon
laquelle la puissance de l’autorité publique
garantit la sécurité nécessaire à la civilisation
;
2. la définition de l’État comme détenteur
du monopole de la violence légitime par le
sociologue allemand Max Weber (Le savant et
le politique) : le pouvoir politique étatique
entraîne le déclin de la violence dans la
communauté, car il l’organise en interdisant
l’usage de la violence à tout membre, groupe,
ou entité de la communauté qui n’agit
pas en tant qu’agent du pouvoir politique.
Comme d’autres empires dans l’histoire
de l’humanité, Rome s’est développée
avec des méthodes brutales, mais ses profits
ont fait progresser la philosophie, les arts,
la justice, et même la morale. Les Romains
justifiaient leur domination en affirmant
qu’ils apportaient aux barbares paix, justice
et raffinement.
L’historien romain Tacite rapporte le discours
du chef breton Calgacus (avant une bataille
contre l’armée romaine), qui dénonce la
brutalité des conquêtes romaines et leur
justification de la violence sous couvert
de civilisation et de paix :
« Ils pillent, tuent et ravissent par faux
prétexte de gouvernement, et là où ils
font un désert, ils l'appellent paix. »
Tacite, Vie d’Agricola
Seulement, d’un autre côté, la violence
est très répandue dans la Rome antique.
Elle se manifeste notamment dans les guerres
d'expansion et de conquête, les combats de
gladiateurs dans les arènes, les exécutions
publiques de criminels et d'esclaves, les
persécutions de certains groupes religieux
comme les chrétiens, la concurrence féroce
pour le pouvoir, ou encore les conflits politiques
internes qui conduisaient souvent à des assassinats
(le plus célèbre étant celui de César).
De surcroît, la mentalité populaire ne condamnait
pas la violence. Dans le Colisée qui symbolise
aujourd’hui l’Empire, des foules comparables
à celles des stades actuels jouissaient du
spectacle de cruautés de masse (nous connaissons
les combats de gladiateurs, mais les spectateurs
pouvaient aussi assister au viol d’une femme
nue attachée à un poteau, ou encore la voir
se faire déchiqueter par des animaux). Autre
exemple emblématique, la crucifixion, qui
est le moyen de mise à mort le plus célèbre
à Rome (c’était d’ailleurs un châtiment
courant dans l’Antiquité), est d’une
cruauté impensable (le prisonnier était
notamment flagellé par une sorte de martinet
dont les lanières étaient serties de pierres
aiguisées qui pénétraient profondément
dans le corps et formaient ainsi des lambeaux
de chair sanguinolente [on peut se faire une
idée de cette torture en regardant le film
La Passion du Christ]).
Quelles formes la violence collective prend-elle
?
La forme de violence collective la plus emblématique
est la guerre, un conflit armé entre des
groupes humains organisés (on parle aussi
de « violence organisée »).
Voltaire a violemment dénoncé la guerre
par la bouche d’un personnage de Candide
(ce qui ne l’a pas empêché de faire grossir
sa fortune en fournissant les armées) :
« Un million d’assassins enrégimentés,
courant d’un bout de l’Europe à l’autre,
exerce le meurtre et le brigandage avec discipline
pour gagner son pain, parce qu’il n’a
pas de métier plus honnête. »
Voltaire, Candide
Voici un bref aperçu de la violence organisée
en Europe depuis la Renaissance :
* de 1400 à 1600, les conflits restent à
un niveau bas, mais constant ;
* les guerres de religion (entre le XVIe et
le XVIIe siècle) représentent un pic de
violence organisée ;
* ça se calme ensuite jusqu’à la fin du
XVIIIe siècle ;
* la Révolution française et l’épopée
napoléonienne relancent la violence ;
* c’est moins violent au milieu et à la
fin du XIXe siècle ;
* la violence organisée explose dans la première
moitié du XXe siècle ;
* une « longue paix » s’installe dans
la seconde moitié du XXe siècle.
Il ressort de cet aperçu que l’Europe moderne
s’est développée dans un contexte de guerres
fréquentes mais peu étendues. D’un côté,
les conflits sont devenus moins nombreux à
mesure que les entités politiques se consolident
en États plus grands. Mais de l’autre côté,
les conflits se firent de plus en plus meurtriers
à cause d’une révolution militaire. Les
guerres modernes mobilisent plus de participants
et impliquent plus de civils. Les armées
sont plus grandes et plus efficaces.
Dans le détail, les États européens mettent
sur place des armées professionnelles permanentes
aux XVIe et XVIIe siècles (c’est la raison
pour laquelle l’impôt devient permanent).
Ils enrôlent un grand nombre d’hommes venant
de toutes les couches de la société, et
non plus uniquement de sa partie la plus misérable.
Ils les préparent au combat organisé en
les entraînant, en les endoctrinant, et en
leur infligeant des punitions sévères. Ils
leur inculquent un code de discipline et de
bravoure. Du coup, lorsque deux armées professionnelles
s’affrontent, les cadavres s’entassent
désormais à une vitesse ahurissante.
Les caractéristiques de la guerre moderne
apparaissent au XIXe siècle :
* la conscription (inaugurée sous la Révolution
française par un décret de 1793), qui est
l’enrôlement des citoyens dans l’armée
par voie de tirage au sort (l’Ukraine et
la Russie y ont recours actuellement) ;
* des armes ainsi que des moyens de communication
et de transport efficaces issus de la révolution
industrielle ;
* le développement de la logistique militaire
;
* les engins mécanisés (la révolution du
tank [impulsée par le générale de Gaulle
en France] et celle de l'avion datent de la
fin de la Première Guerre mondiale) ;
* une course à l’innovation dans l’armement.
Ainsi, la guerre est la forme de violence
collective la plus emblématique parce qu’elle
est une constante de l’histoire de l’Europe
du deuxième millénaire. Pour les classes
dirigeantes, elle fait partie de l’ordre
des choses. Les élites considèrent donc
la paix comme un bref intervalle entre deux
guerres.
Pour autant, la guerre n’est pas l’unique
forme de violence collective.
On distingue encore :
* des violences diffuses comme des rixes,
des bagarres entre groupes, entre communautés
villageoises ou religieuses, des émeutes
populaires contre la vie chère, le brigandage,
le banditisme (de telles violences surgissaient
souvent en Europe jusqu’au XVIIIe siècle
lors d’explosions de misère ou de révoltes
contre l’impôt, et les émeutes de banlieues
sont un exemple moderne) ;
* les soulèvements et révolutions (les révolutions
anglaises de 1642 et 1688, la Révolution
française de 1789, les journées révolutionnaires
européennes tout au long du XIXe siècle,
la révolution russe de 1917 sont les exemples
les plus connus) : il s’agit d’une violence
collective « moderne » (les violences diffuses
étant des formes « anciennes ») qui présuppose
l’identification d'un pouvoir central à
conquérir et un projet général de réorganisation
de la société ;
* la violence de l’autorité politique pour
établir, maintenir, ou faire fonctionner
le pouvoir politique (ex : despotes et tyrans,
répression politique [exercée par les forces
de maintien de l’ordre dans les États modernes],
terreur révolutionnaire) ;
* le terrorisme (qui se développe spectaculairement
depuis les années 1960), défini comme un
acte de violence prémédité commis par un
acteur non étatique contre des civils avec
un objectif politique, religieux ou social
visant à forcer la main à un gouvernement,
à intimider la population ou à transmettre
un message à un public plus large ;
* la guerre civile, un conflit armé qui oppose
des groupes au sein d'un même pays et qui
engendre souvent l’ultraviolence (tortures,
exécutions sommaires, mutilations, viols,
meurtres de masse).
Comment expliquer la violence collective ?
Étant donné que la guerre est un fond omniprésent
de l’histoire des civilisations, les penseurs
occidentaux ont tenté de l’élucider.
Voici 3 théories de référence :
1. Thucydide, l’historien athénien du Ve
siècle avant J.-C. qui a donné naissance
à l’histoire telle que nous la concevons
aujourd’hui, étudie les causes de la guerre
dans La Guerre du Péloponnèse, où il raconte
le conflit qui a opposé Athènes à Sparte
entre 431 av. J.-C. et 404 av. J.-C. De son
point de vue, les conflits entre États s’expliquent
principalement par la peur, par la concurrence
pour les ressources, ou par la volonté de
puissance des dirigeants. Il estime par exemple
que la peur, plus précisément la tendance
d’une puissance établie à agresser préventivement
une puissance émergente, est la cause fondamentale
de la guerre du Péloponnèse.
« La cause la plus vraie [et] aussi la moins
avouée [de la guerre] : c’est à mon sens
que les Athéniens, en s’accroissant, donnèrent
de l’appréhension aux Lacédémoniens,
les contraignant ainsi à la guerre. »
Thucydide, La Guerre du Péloponnèse
C’est ce que les géopolitologues et spécialistes
des relations internationales appellent le
« piège de Thucydide ». Ce concept leur
fait par exemple craindre que les États-Unis
attaquent la Chine afin de préserver leur
hégémonie.
2. Kant, le plus grand philosophe allemand
des Lumières, veut résoudre le problème
de la guerre dans De la paix perpétuelle.
Il part du principe que les États continueront
de s’agresser en l’absence d’ordre politique
international. Il plaide donc pour l’établissement
d’un système de coopération qui ait le
pouvoir de tenir les nations en respect, solution
qui revient à établir un « Léviathan international
». Il met en évidence une autre cause de
la guerre : les gouvernements non démocratiques.
En effet, les démocraties tendent à éviter
la guerre dans la mesure où les bénéfices
de la guerre vont à ceux qui règnent sur
un pays, tandis que le coût en est payé
par les citoyens.
3. Clausewitz, un théoricien militaire prussien
du XIXe siècle, confronte la théorie à
la réalité du terrain. Il est l’auteur
de la fameuse formule selon laquelle la guerre
est la continuation de la politique par d’autres
moyens. L’Italien Machiavel avait déjà
affirmé à la Renaissance dans Le Prince
qu’un dirigeant politique peut recourir
à la guerre pour préserver ou étendre son
pouvoir.
« La guerre n’est pas seulement un acte
politique, mais un véritable instrument politique,
une continuation des relations politiques,
un accomplissement de celles-ci par d’autres
moyens. »
Clausewitz, De la guerre
En pratique, la guerre s’arrête lorsque
le vainqueur est satisfait par ce qu’il
a obtenu et qu’il est en mesure d’empêcher
le vaincu de se réarmer. Dans le détail,
le calcul politique préconise l’arrêt
du conflit lorsque la supériorité de l’un
des belligérants ne peut plus être renversée,
ou lorsque la situation ne peut plus être
évaluée. La stratégie et les aléas font
comparer la guerre à un jeu, mais elle est
un moyen sérieux au service d’une fin sérieuse.
Clausewitz estime que les enjeux politiques
et les réalités du champ de bataille empêchent
la montée aux extrêmes que laissent craindre
les passions humaines. La guerre moderne est
une ritualisation de la violence : les adversaires
s’entendent ​​pour ne pas dépasser
certaines limites et ne pas sortir de certaines
formes.
Les penseurs ont également théorisé les
autres formes de violence collective :
* Aristote dit dans Les Politiques que les
inégalités et le mépris des dirigeants
sont susceptibles de provoquer la violence
des groupes sociaux défavorisés. Le marxisme
requalifiera les violences diffuses comme
des conflits de classe. Le freudisme les requalifiera,
lui, comme une libération d’inhibitions.
* Pareto, un sociologue italien des XIXe et
XXe siècles, conçoit une révolution comme
le remplacement d’une élite qui a perdu
sa compétence et sa volonté de puissance
par une nouvelle élite (par exemple, la bourgeoisie
a remplacé la noblesse lors de la Révolution
française). Cette théorie développée dans
le Traité de sociologie générale de Pareto
s’appelle la « circulation des élites
». L’histoire des sociétés est celle
de la succession de minorités privilégiées
qui se forment, luttent, arrivent au pouvoir,
en profitent et tombent en décadence, pour
être remplacées par d’autres minorités.
« L’histoire est un cimetière d’aristocraties.
»
Pareto, Traité de sociologie générale
* Machiavel justifie la violence de l’autorité
dans Le Prince comme un moyen nécessaire
pour atteindre certains objectifs. Probablement
marqué par l’instabilité et l’insécurité
de l’Italie de son époque, il voit les
hommes ordinaires comme des tyrans en puissance
susceptibles de détruire l’ordre social
si les dirigeants ne savent pas user de la
force au bon moment. La Boétie, un humaniste
français du XVIe siècle, abordera la question
du point de vue de la multitude opprimée
dans son fameux Discours de la servitude volontaire.
Si une multitude peut être soumise à un
tyran, qui est seul et pas moins faible que
chacun, c’est parce qu’elle est fascinée
et paralysée dans la crainte.
* Serge Netchaïev, un révolutionnaire russe
du XIXe siècle, prône la violence et la
destruction sans réserve pour atteindre les
objectifs révolutionnaires. Dans son Catéchisme
du révolutionnaire, il appelle les révolutionnaires
à utiliser tous les moyens nécessaires,
y compris la terreur, pour renverser l'ordre
établi. Lénine, le premier dirigeant de
l’URSS, défendra la même thèse une cinquantaine
d’années plus tard dans son essai Leur
morale et la nôtre. Le titre signifie que
la révolution communiste ne doit pas être
jugée à l’aune de la morale bourgeoise,
qui est faussement universelle, mais à l’aune
de la morale révolutionnaire, qui confère
une valeur morale à tout ce qui fait avancer
la cause révolutionnaire.
* Platon (La République) conçoit la guerre
civile comme une maladie interne qui détruit
le corps politique de l’intérieur. Elle
porte la rivalité entre les hommes à son
comble. Le risque est grand en démocratie,
car elle répand le laxisme à tous les niveaux
de la société (il contamine même le monde
animal, estime Platon). Aristote (Les Politiques),
qui réfléchit de manière plus concrète,
met en lumière la même cause fondamentale
— la rivalité entre les hommes — mais
il estime que le risque est plus grand dans
une oligarchie, parce que ce sont souvent
les luttes entre grandes familles qui engendrent
les guerres civiles.
L’humanité devient-elle de plus en plus
violente ?
Le psychologue canadien Steven Pinker (qui
est prof à Harvard) a réalisé un sondage
auprès de citoyens anglais. Les gens interrogés
estiment que le XXe siècle a été un peu
plus violent que le XIVe siècle en termes
d’homicides. En réalité, malgré les guerres
mondiales, les génocides, les totalitarismes,
etc., le taux d’homicides a été divisé
par 100 entre le XIVe et le XXe siècle. Ce
sondage montre que les générations modernes
oublient la propension à la violence de leurs
ancêtres.
Dans les faits, le déclin de la violence
est incontestable. La tendance globale est
sans équivoque, visible à des échelles
qui se comptent en millénaires ou en années,
qu’on considère les campagnes guerrières
ou les fessées données aux enfants.
Voici quelques éléments de preuve :
* Le passage du mode de vie du chasseur-cueilleur
à l'agriculture a divisé la probabilité
d’une mort violence par environ 5 (estiment
les anthropologues).
* En Europe, le taux d’homicide est passé
de 100 par an pour 100 000 habitants au XIVe
siècle, à 10 au XVIIe siècle, et à 1 de
nos jours. En France, il y a deux fois moins
de meurtres dans les années 2010 que dans
les années 1990.
* Les guerres du passé ont causé des effets
bien plus ravageurs (rapportés à la population
totale) qu’il ne le paraît si on prend
en compte leurs effets indirects, tels que
les famines et les maladies.
* Du Moyen Âge à l’époque classique,
les populations faisaient les frais des rivalités
entre pouvoirs locaux. Les chevaliers, comtes,
ducs et princes ne cessaient de s’attaquer
et de se venger des agressions passées en
s’efforçant de ruiner leurs adversaires,
en tuant et mutilant les paysans, en brûlant
les villages et en détruisant les récoltes.
* Jusqu’au XVIIIe siècle, la torture était
pratiquée ouvertement. La pendaison, le supplice
de la roue, l’empalement, l’écartèlement
par des chevaux et le supplice du bûcher
étaient monnaie courante.
* L’histoire européenne comprend également
des phénomènes de violence de grande ampleur
comme l’esclavage, l’Inquisition, ou la
chasse aux sorcières.
* La violence domestique, qui est une des
formes de violence les plus répandues dans
le monde, a baissé de manière spectaculaire
au cours du IIe millénaire.
En définitive, l’Europe occidentale du
tournant du XXIe siècle est le lieu le plus
sûr de l’histoire de l’humanité. Son
taux d'homicide avoisinant une victime pour
100 000 habitants est le plancher qu’il
est possible d’atteindre, car même la plus
paisible des sociétés ne peut pas éradiquer
la violence. De plus, une violence modérée
sera toujours nécessaire sous la forme de
forces de police et d’armées, afin de dissuader
la prédation ou de mettre hors d’état
de nuire ceux qui ne se laissent pas dissuader.
« Le déclin de la violence est la chose
la plus importante qui se soit jamais produite
dans l'histoire de l'humanité. »
Steven Pinker, La part d'ange en nous
Comment expliquer le déclin de la violence
humaine ?
Le sociologue allemand Norbert Elias donne
une réponse convaincante dans son chef-d’œuvre
Sur le processus de civilisation. Il attribue
la diminution de la violence en Europe à
une vaste évolution psychologique consécutive
à la diffusion de nouvelles normes sociales
depuis la fin du Moyen Âge. Les individus
ont appris à inhiber leurs pulsions, anticiper
les conséquences à long terme et considérer
les pensées et sentiments d'autrui. La culture
de l'honneur légitimant la vengeance a été
remplacée par une culture de la dignité
qui valorise la maîtrise de soi. Ce nouvel
idéal s’est propagé des aristocrates et
chevaliers aux autres classes, jusqu’à
intégrer finalement la culture dans son ensemble.
Cependant, ce processus de civilisation repose
lui-même sur d’autres facteurs (la centralisation
des monarchies et la prospérité, notamment),
et d’autres évolutions ultérieures ont
contribué à pacifier les sociétés occidentales.
Voici les facteurs les plus probables du déclin
de la violence :
* L’émergence d’États stables a réduit
les violences entre individus et groupes,
qui doivent désormais résoudre leurs conflits
par l’intermédiaire d’institutions et
de processus légaux (cette évolution correspond
à la théorie du Léviathan de Hobbes et
à celle du monopole de la violence légitime
de Weber). Des États stables sont également
plus à même d’éviter la guerre grâce
à la diplomatie.
* Le développement du commerce (qui est d’ailleurs
favorisé par l’émergence d’États stables)
a stimulé la coopération et rendu la violence
coûteuse. À partir de la fin du Moyen Âge,
les royaumes en pleine expansion ont consolidé
une infrastructure d’échanges, notamment
à travers la monnaie et l’application des
contrats. Cette infrastructure, la construction
de routes et d’horloges, la levée des tabous
frappant l’intérêt, l’innovation et
la concurrence — tout cela a rendu le commerce
plus attrayant. Peu à peu les marchands,
artisans et bureaucrates ont remplacé les
preux chevaliers.
* La féminisation des sociétés réduit
la violence des jeunes hommes (la violence
étant largement le fait d’hommes qui ont
entre 15 et 30 ans). La psychologie évolutionniste
explique que les cultures qui respectent davantage
les intérêts et les valeurs des femmes amenuisent
la concurrence entre les mâles. L’une de
ces dispositions est le mariage, par lequel
les hommes s’engagent à investir dans les
enfants qu’ils engendrent plutôt que de
rivaliser les uns avec les autres pour des
opportunités sexuelles. Se marier réduit
le taux de testostérone des hommes, ainsi
que la probabilité de les voir basculer dans
la criminalité.
* L’expansion de l’empathie signifie que
l’homme veut le bien de plus en plus de
ses semblables, et même d’autres êtres.
Le philosophe australien Peter Singer (connu
comme l’auteur de la bible de la défense
des droits des animaux) avance dans The Expanding
Circle que les êtres humains ont été pourvus,
par la sélection naturelle, d’un noyau
d’empathie envers leurs proches et leurs
alliés, et qu’ils ont graduellement étendu
cette empathie à des cercles toujours plus
larges d’êtres vivants, de la famille et
du village au clan, à la tribu, à la nation,
à l’espèce, puis enfin à l’ensemble
des êtres doués de sensibilité.
* Le progrès de la rationalité décrédibilise
des justifications de la violence. En particulier,
la scolarisation du XXe siècle a démocratisé
l’intelligence abstraite qui favorise la
maîtrise de soi et l’empathie en donnant
à l’individu la faculté de s’extraire
de son expérience immédiate. Le raisonnement
scientifique imprègne désormais les raisonnements
de la vie quotidienne.
Le déclin de la violence aboutit à l’idéal
de la non-violence qui prévaut en Occident,
où les individus deviennent sensibles à
toute forme d’agression. Cette évolution
est illustrée par la diffusion du concept
de « micro-agression » (inventé par un
psychiatre de Harvard à la fin des Trente
Glorieuses), qui désigne une discrimination
subtile (une remarque, par exemple) envers
un membre d’une communauté marginalisée.
Ainsi, les mentalités élargissent la notion
de violence jusqu’à en faire un synonyme
de « domination ». S’impose alors l'idée
que « tout est violence ».
Quoique fiable, le constat du déclin de la
violence mérite 2 nuances principales :
1. il n’est pas toujours facile de comparer
les sociétés modernes avec celles du passé,
qui ne disposaient pas des mêmes capacités
d’archivage ;
2. il y a des essors de violence sur de courtes
périodes, comme lors de la révolution culturelle
occidentale qui s’étend grosso modo de
1960 à 1990 (d’ailleurs, en valorisant
l’expression libre et naturelle, la révolution
culturelle est allée à rebours de l’évolution
psychologique du « processus de civilisation
» mise en évidence par Norbert Elias, qui
repose sur la maîtrise de soi).
________________
Si tu aimes l’esprit de cette vidéo, à
savoir travailler avec des idées claires
pour être le plus efficace possible, alors
tu devrais t’inscrire à mes 50 paragraphes
« tout cuits » sur le thème de la violence.
Ce sont 50 paragraphes prêts à l'emploi
qui couvrent tous les arguments possibles
sur le thème de la violence, avec dans chaque
paragraphe la référence idéale (la plupart
du temps classique, mais aussi parfois originale)
pour justifier l’argument. Ils sont accompagnés
d’une cinquantaine de plans détaillés
modèles qui permettent de traiter tous les
sujets possibles.
Du coup, tu réussiras facilement tes dissertations
sans apprendre ton cours, sans chercher un
plan ni des arguments, et sans rédiger le
développement.
Tu seras scandaleusement surnoté(e) grâce
au style simple, fluide, efficace et facile
à imiter avec lequel je rédige les paragraphes.
Enfin, mes 50 paragraphes « tout cuits », c’est
aussi la solution la plus rapide pour préparer
un DS. Grâce à la playlist audio, tes révisions
se résumeront à écouter les paragraphes
pendant 1 heure dans toutes les circonstances
imaginables : en marchant, en courant, dans
les transports, à la salle de sport, ou encore…
au fond de la classe !
Par exemple, Léa m’a raconté qu’elle
écoutait les paragraphes en faisant du vélo
d’appartement, et qu’étant donné qu’elle
en faisait chaque jour, elle savait tout ce
qu’elle avait besoin de savoir pour ses
dissertations de culture générale sans avoir
passé une seule minute dans son cours.
Comme ça fait 7 ans que je propose mes paragraphes
« tout cuits », j’ai reçu beaucoup d’autres
témoignages.
Regarde celui-ci qui date de 2017 : « L’année
dernière, je plafonnais à 8 en dissertation,
j’étais dans les tous derniers. Aujourd’hui,
le prof rend les copies, je majore la classe
avec 17. »
Effectivement, l’avantage de mes paragraphes
« tout cuits », c’est que tu gagnes des
points rapidement, pas dans 6 mois mais dès
le prochain DS.
Le prochain témoignage est celui d’Alex.
Il m’a écrit sur Messenger : « Je me suis
rappelé que je ne t’avais jamais remercié
pour ta méthode (qui m’a, on peut le dire,
sauvé). »
Alex dit que mes paragraphes « tout cuits
» l’ont sauvé parce que la culture générale
n’était pas sa matière forte et qu’en
plus il ne l’a quasiment pas travaillée.
Avec son niveau, il pensait se ramasser aux
concours — mais il a fini avec 13 à HEC
et 15 à l’ESSEC (la prestigieuse école
qu’il a intégrée).
Le dernier témoignage que je veux te montrer
est un peu drôle. Roland m’écrit : « Même
si j’ai eu 15/20, je pense que c’est plutôt
grâce à tes paragraphes tout cuits très
bien rédigés plutôt que grâce à ma dissertation.
»
Roland pense qu’il a été surnoté parce
que le style de mes paragraphes « tout cuits
» a fait sortir sa copie du lot.
Je sais, j’ai promis que c’était le dernier
témoignage — mais je veux quand même t’en
montrer un tout dernier, parce que c’est
celui d’un prof. J’ai flouté beaucoup
de choses dans son e-mail parce qu’il est
prof de culture générale dans une prépa
prestigieuse (en plus d’être correcteur
à HEC).
Il m’écrit notamment : « Votre méthode
est excellente et correspond tout à fait
à ce que je crois être efficace pour la
préparation des concours. »
J’ai même rencontré ce prof, et il m’a
avoué qu’il faisait désormais la même
chose que moi : il prépare des paragraphes
modèles pour sa classe.
Voilà voilà, je t’ai déjà montré un
témoignage de plus que ce que j’avais promis
— il y a encore beaucoup d’autres sur
la page de présentation.
Si tu veux en savoir plus sur mes paragraphes
« tout cuits », clique sur le lien qui apparaît
en haut à droite de la vidéo ; ou bien clique
sur celui qui est dans la description ; ou
bien encore tape directement https://1000idcg.com/50ptc
dans la barre de recherche.
Et puis si tu as des questions, écris-moi
à romain@1000idcg.com.
Bon courage pour le travail !